today on Battle Damage we see if this
brand new Apple iPad holds up to our
three trials by fire well we know the
iPad with Retina display aka the iPad 4
is designed to be tough we're about to
push it to its limits there are three
basic tests here on battle damage drop
from a normal height drop from really
high and finally a random act of
complete and utter destruction
and we'll be capturing every moment in
glorious slow-motion from the unique
angle of our hand-built 360 degree
camera rig ready action
totally undamaged check the bottom house
bottom well scratch the bottoms fine
videos playing fine so definitely still
usable after test one ready action
Wow
it's like a little scuffed up right here
it looks a little bent that's insane
people who definitely still use iPads
there and we're shaping this whole
nervous but hitting it the exact proper
time ready action
oh it's still on it still works
I mean I don't know how well you'd be
able to play a game what do you guys
want to see us battle test next leave a
comment down there in the comment
section below or on social media with
the hashtag battle damage and get eco
fix it I think they will we'll see you
next time
I need these replaced with an apple care
sure